jillian wendy martimer commonly known as
jill mortimer
conservative party candidate 15529
john prescott reform uk 368 votes
thelma doris walker independent 250
votes
william rath war jackson commonly known
as w
bathwar jackson independent 157 votes
and paul daniel williams for the labour
party 8589 votes
the number of ballot papers the number
of ballot papers rejected was as follows
61 voting for more candidates than a
voter was entitled to
and 121 being unmarked or wholly void
for
uncertainty i do there i do hereby
declare
that jillian wendy mortimer commonly
known as jill mortimer
is duly elected congratulations
[Applause]
so that's the majority of about 7 000
for
jill mortimer here she is now making her
victory speech
thank you madam returning officer
firstly i want to thank the police and
the council officers
who have done an excellent job in
ensuring that today's election and count
went smoothly especially given the
difficult circumstances we've faced
due to the coronavirus pandemic i'd also
like to thank all the candidates
on the stage it's been a tough contest
but it's one that's been fought with
dignity and respect
so thank you all i'm incredibly proud of
the campaign my team and i have run in
hartlepool
it's based on local issues of real
concern to the community here
and i'd like to thank all of the people
of this great town who've responded so
positively to it i'm also
immensely proud to be the first
conservative mp
in hartlepool for 57 years
not only that i am the first woman ever
to be elected
as mp for this town
[Applause]
it's a truly historic result and a
momentous day
labor of tank people in hartley pull for
granted for too long
um i heard this time and time again on
the doorstep
people have had enough and now through
this result
the people have spoken and they've made
it clear
it's time for change people voted for
that positive
change for jobs and investment and it's
exactly what i'm going to deliver
for now i just want to say a few more
thank yous
directly those to those people who voted
for me who put their faith in me
thank you from the bottom of my heart um
i'm going to work tirelessly for harley
pool and i will not let you down
i will not fail you i'll work with both
the conservative government
and the t side valley mayor and i very
much hope it will once again be ben
houchin and we can celebrate with him
again
tomorrow my thanks also go to cchq
everyone in my fantastic campaign team
and all those who supported me
throughout this a election
including my agent and very proudly my
friend diane clark obe
and of course the wonderful hashon cohen
and of course my heartfelt thanks go to
all of my family
they know who they all are they're more
than just my blood relatives
for their unwavering support
and finally election campaigns are only
made possible by hard-working volunteers
people who are willing to sacrifice
their time pound the streets with us in
as we've seen this time baking sun
frozen letter boxes and hail
political parties rely on the
selflessness of these volunteers
and without them our democracies and
communities would be so much purer
poorer
so thank you all once again